citizens of the reject Nation we are here
for the Mandalorian season thrust today I
am more than enthusiastic about it I've said this
several times mandolin is my favorite thing Star
Wars has ever done come at me in the comments
people of course joined by John John how are
you John I'm excited to be here sir and Michael
my bad batch friend how are you this is this is
the moment I'm so excited this is what we built
towards right here if you don't know Michael is
uh easily the the most knowledgeable person
I know when it comes to Star Wars so excited
to have you here follow him at multihouse.io
people use the force to leave a like you know
how we do also subscribe click that notification
Bell to get notified when our reaction for the
next episode of the Mandalorian is up here on
this channel as always full length reaction
Watcher long story sync up with your own copy
of Mandalorian available for our super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page we cover several
things exclusively over there with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included and if
you haven't done and watched along with us
before at our patreon well the first episode
of any new season is public for everyone so
there's a link in the pink comment if you do
want to do this sync up with us uh but the
rest will be patreon exclusive let's just
watch this come on what are we waiting for
I love how they're not doing music for this oh boy
that Lucas Sound Library boy
look at that characters in there
the armor find a new place to
make sure what a nice Forge
of the Mythos are just right
there yeah right Clash of best car
oh forging of a new helmet I
wonder if this is a flashback
I wonder what they make their paint out of
oh interesting ah is she making them for
oh okay new recruits
cool
you might be right about the flashback
yeah little baby Den baby's first helmet
he was there the whole time yeah Mr vizla
is awesome I swear in the names of the ants
pretty shall be forever forged in my heart
and the words of the Creed shall be forever
forged in my heart fizzle was watching like
you better never take that damn helmet
off I'm gonna hold it against you forever
a helmet depressurized this is the way this
is the way this is the way this is the way
from this moment on I shall never remove
my helmet from this moment on I shall never
oh my gosh
oh my God
worst baptism ever no it's a test
little baby Mandos oh you're crazy stunts
always reclaiming the jet pack
I think we're gonna punch it yeah oh
take that damn they Starship Troopers
that guy's got a channel he just uploads his GoPro
footage you think this is cool you
should see a Mandalorian quinceanera
oh my God
oh man
God didn't prove yourself
take it down single-handed
oh come on Armor
tongs that is so scary
shine bucko
no way damn hell yeah it's a good fake
out the music whoa that's an N1 wait a
minute now this is not a flashback it's not
a flashback yeah good fake out oh baby baby
holy crap oh they did the boys
on it the viscera oh man oh man
that's a good fake out yeah that was like
that little boy does not look like he was
a very pale it's a white passing let's see
though they're out there God you paid them
all back yeah right we'll be back in now jeez
from the first season for helping it out yeah
did you go to the mines yet huh
remove your helmet this again
you are no longer Mandalorian
the Creed teaches us of redemption
all was destroyed in The Purge is this
inscription not Mandalorian description you say
Kryptonite where did you come upon this
Jawas of course traveler who claimed to
have visited the surface of Mandalore and
this Relic only proves that mandalore's entire
surface has been crystallized by Fusion race
but a traveler was able to retrieve
this so perhaps it is not poisoned
if I visit the planet and I can bring you proof
that I have bathed in the Living Waters beneath
the minds of Mandalore the decree of Exile will
be lifted and I would be redeemed easily fake that
denjar that is the way the way of After Effects
this is the way I will accept your shower video
oh his little chainmail
I will never get over this N1
literally us watching the Mandalorian
the space whales yeah from Rebels yeah is
it exactly that that is exactly what it is
I wonder if only grogu can
see them it's really beautiful
it's a really solid setup for Ahsoka that's what I
wanted this episode I want to focus
on anything other than the right now
is this Navara welcome to Navarro is
Navara okay please State the purpose
of your visit here to meet an
old friend Bando that's great
welcome to come to the Navarro Gem of
the outer ring it's all thriving I know
it just gets prettier every season that's
a Fresh coat of paint canceled cobblestone
oh look at the chef chappie likes to cook oh
okay love me some mon calamari on Navarro
I want one
a lot has changed around here I know it's
like a time dilation happens it's just me
and any RPG upgrading my Village looks like
a Gondor now yeah that's exactly oh my God
I was wondering why he was in the recap
that's incredible he gave his life
do you remember your old friend he
almost murdered you the best damn
Nanny this Galaxy's ever seen
what a glow up seriously it's the drip Droid
magistrate cargo that's high magistrate cargo
to you get it right let's catch up on
old times but don't bring up Cara Dune
who you win the little one you
can settle down you can hang up
your blaster live off the fat of the land
nice groku come again his name is grogu
it's a statue of himself in the back
I completed my quest he returned to me
I removed my helmet and now I'm an apostate say
all the more reason for you to stay here with us
magistrate High magistrate yes hi magistrate
apologies average I reached the courtyard
stand aside Droid don't you know who we are
come on vain that'll be enough of that Bane
let's continue this conversation
back in my office this is a school
join me for a drink back at my
office we'll toast to your captain
we drink here man I should have named the
school after him drink at the school that is
a school now I say it's still a bar is there
a problem here magistrate High Magistrate
you paid us for murder and Mayhem inside
these doors like a cross between Voldemort
and Davey Jones yep that's a good call
sounds like you went soft you think so
it's a grief Tater ship my guy
did you like to settle
oh code Captain Julian shark that
Navarro is no longer friendly to Pirates
now get out of here well that one blast in
every town screaming it's a different place now
he'll let it be known that Navarro is respectable
now and not to be trifled with I'll respect a
better not kill off grief in this season
I need a marshall what about Marshall Dune
she was recruited by Special Forces and what
came up Gideon why is that I can't serve as your
Marshall I have something pressing to attend
to I didn't know you were here on business
what can we provide forever together
I need him back what these are his
parts are they not I mean what's
left of them oh I need a Droid I can
trust to help me explore Mandalore
and he's that Droid that is cool reboot his
Consciousness it's like not at the Museum
all right I'm so happy right now finally a place
we can all agree upon taika if we can wake him up
it's a hot wire and a car it's
a little baby Annie could do it
no there you go kill me
oh my God
oh they must have puppeteered
and sped it up or something
no you're bust
no that's using your head
man's got jokes fortunately Navarro has
attracted the best Droid Smiths of the outer rim
Bobby Frick why don't you ask him
for yourself oh the unsealants
is it his racer actually Babu Frick that's really
hard to tell they're all Babu Frick it's so pretty
wise yeah they can fuse together like the stations
in Bill and Ted oh my God I love these claymation
looking so silly now the different arrays of like
animation and puppeteering right oh that's amazing
he said he can't fix it this one is
my friend they're not friend anymore
don't make new ones very hard to
find he said they don't make him
anymore they're very hard to find I got it
this one it says you should get a new one
I want a new one what destroyed what if I
find you the part okay now then no problem
oh
don't eat Babu Frick hey baby
that's the spin-off bad Patch baby oh my
God that was so magical if the enzylins
can't find it I don't know who can safe
travels the Jawas can find it oh boy
oh man being a Maureen's not just learning about
how to fight you also have to know
how to navigate the Galaxy and this
trouble hang on kid we got Pirates oh brother
Alpha Revenge we have pirate king goryan shards
man uh we'll answer to him going in short
should stick to hijacking and ransoming
I'm picking fights you can't win
like how they waited until he was like a
midier field it's my favorite Star Fox level
three more
oh man
the cinematography of The Season's
off to a phenomenal start cheese
Space Battles in Mandalorian
it was fun it's just me and Star Tours
in Disney World what are you doing here
I'm gonna show it behind
your asses do a barrel roll
Michael Myers on you Mando Myers
I have you now nice
oh
beautiful wow bringing the
Mandalorian to you captain
oh my gosh yeah buddy bait that's a cool ship
dick ferric they have a Target lock on us
clearly where you are wow I have no quarrel with
you Guardian Shard yeah what a kind sentiment so
was that about Davey Jones Surrender
Your Ship and I'll spare your life
kid never trust a pirate uh so long Swamp Thing
problem averted not the last we'll see of him this
was like a rick yeah whatever his name is another
planet in the Mandalorian system and that is a
Mandalorian Castle I don't need cool cool cool
I haven't seen one of these since
Rebels who's he this is this vocatan
it's probably Clan Cruise's Castle yes that makes
sense or the night owls Fortress it's
the library from Blade Runner 2049.
actually looks like they're entering
Halos sci-fi salad spoke 10. it is
all mandalorians Lounge the same when I
returned without the dark saber my forces
melted away where is the stolen Fleet making
their way through the Galaxy as Mercenaries
you lead them wave that thing around and
they'll do whatever you say so you gave up
your designs to retake Mandalore your cult
gave up on Mandalore long before The Purge
they're all part of a cold a network of Cults
it's a religion the children of the watch and
all the factions that came before fractured and
shattered our people we're in Death Watch come
on I am going to Mandalore and be forgiven for
my transgressions you are a fool that planet has
been ravaged plundered and poisoned you said
that the curse was a lie make up your mind
if you want to go to the mines be my guest they're
beneath the Civic Center in the city of sundari
ah Civic Center and I will find out
if the planet is really poisoned
what if you die vanilla found it out goodbye
Katie sackhoff's great ah yeah right did she
just sit there that's all she does all day
he had a very distinct style for the in the
episodes he did for one there's tonally and
then when it it was when the it was
fighting the bad guys at the end that
reminded me of the prison one with Bill
Burr I was like this feels like John you
take it away first this was a blast this
is an absolute blast of a return blast
this is good because because he's just your
delivery they're very much reminded me of William
Shatner for some reason anyway uh he knows yeah
that's what it was oh good then my sci-fi Tunes
are are right on pie walk past him the other day
in fact it was great uh anyway this is a really
great uh return to me I really liked the way they
crested from just this opening set piece this you
know big sense of scale and Adventure you know
a big monster battle and then you get back into
what the next you know uh serial part of the
story is we're trying to find that Redemption
for din jar and in the waters beneath the mines
of Mandalore and uh and yeah I mean you know they
haven't reinvented the wheel in terms of how the
show moves but it just feels like putting on like
a like an old sweater it's like it's it's nice
to be back in this place where you have just this
interesting sort of episodic check back in with
what's happening on Navarro and everything with
grief carga and then you know checking in with
Boca tan really quick before we really launch
into the adventure but uh yeah I felt like this
this was like a really fun and satisfying return
that has yeah all those threads of where we'll go
to come but for right now just you know kind of
of a slam dunk of just jumping back in the pool
you know to mix all sorts of physical metaphors
Mikhail I completely agree and I personally feel
like you know in in the first season it was it was
such a character character focused piece where
it was intimate it was personal and I feel like
the Mandalorian is one of those very few shows
that has earned the world feeling bigger and I
love returning to some of these locations
seeing the changes uh and and then just
seeing these these two characters slowly kind of
start to find their place in a much bigger Galaxy
um you know I think from like Big Star Wars
nerd perspective I just like I could watch like
Mandalorian rituals all day and be super happy
uh and even like the the little details like the
Mandalorian starting to you know understanding
that the Jedi won't be training grogu in in the
ways of the force uh didn't jar in understanding
that you know somebody has to still teach grogu
and in this case now it's going to be in in the
way of the Mandalorian and I I love that you know
we're gonna start seeing that Evolution but great
callbacks I mean this just felt so cinematic and
so big um and I'm just I'm so excited for the
rest of the season big yeah it's different than
the than the other ones in a lot of ways because
this felt the most light-hearted and it's right I
mean if you're there's there's certain elements
that obviously like tie into the first episode
of of the whole series you know with seeing uh
some of the familiar mandalorians and then uh
like that it's it's also interesting about how
the set how the season two their first episode
ended with taking out a giant monster and this
starts off with taking down a giant monster uh
so it's like a kind of an inverse of it so yeah
they have that of course Navarro and it's always
felt a little bit more desolate and a little bit
more uh gritty and this felt like the least gritty
of them all and that's not a bad thing it actually
felt like it's just another element of Star Wars
it's another layer of Star Wars I am wondering
though if that is very intentional definitely
whereas Mandalorian often goes from you know
something that could be dark to ending hopeful
like they already said they already have season
four written out so the fact that it started
off so hopeful like this has such a it's like
the other seasons have such an immediate rush
and Pace to it because it's a fugitive story
they're on the road they're they're on the
road that he's got like I gotta take this guy to
you know the Jedi like at least with the second
season I gotta take this guy's Jedi but people
are still hunting him the Empire's after him so
there's like there's a there's an intensity to it
we're here it's like I can kind of take my time
but I just I do want to become a Mandalorian you
know like there's no real ticking time clock yet
but I feel like something is around the corner and
you could feel that there's something brewing and
if there's anything we know about mandalorians is
that while they're teasing him possibly you know
leading the ways of the Mandalore you lead the
mandalorians I'm like a lot of times mandalorians
that end up in their own little Civil Wars all the
time they love their Civil Wars yeah it sure is
um to not commit violence is a sin uh in
in their in their Creed and in their faith
um but you know I I completely agree I feel
like all of the challenges of previous Seasons
even like this like random pirate like like it's
amazing how just like yeah in one episode we're
gonna show you that the stakes are clearly going
to be much higher um and I think they're not there
yet no they're not there yet and I think this is
the kind of sorry to interject I just I know the
trajectory of how these things go because I will
say like yeah there are parts of this that felt a
little bit fast there are parts that felt a little
bit like okay we're going through this a little
quick certain parts not a lot but certain parts
and however this is one of those things where
you gotta take the season as a whole you know like
even if I had a qualm like that slightly with any
part of season two when you watch it all at once
you're like no it's pretty pretty near perfect
season and I'd imagine that whatever the whole
package is this at least I'm hopeful for that I
don't know I mean that's the one thing that got me
a little worried about it well even book of Boba
Fett still had a couple of really important gems
sure sprinkled in that I think helped uh really
set this season up for Success um but I feel
like the in in John Favreau and Dave filoni uh
something I've really admired about this episode
was we're beginning to see the Galaxy or parts of
the Galaxy heal from the repercussions of the
Empire and I feel like what's also interesting
as they kind of go backwards and trying to
fill in the blanks of how did Palpatine return
um but really no uh I feel like we're we're seeing
even the distrust on Navarro of the Republic and
this idea of a a fear of of going back and you
know I think the the mandalorians in the same way
uh having just rewatched clone wars and Rebels
um whatever happens next is going to be really
really hard for them to come to a consensus on
and and building that trust uh and that Faith
In following a singular leader uh especially
one who's an outsider uh I'm I'm really excited
um but it seems to me our two Rivals here
are going to be bo Katan and the armorer
um with the Mandalorian being a bridge between
these two you know I I think I think once the
Mandalorian proves to them uh that Mandalore
which was for the record it was like uninhabitable
prior they just made it more like the capital
was in a dome because everything else had been
previously destroyed so like it's worth the
Mandalore that's what they've said yeah I
just keep rebuilding over and over again I mean
heck Concord Dawn I mean the planet was literally
just like ripped in half and they still settled
there so get over yourselves mandalorians rebuild
there's always a path to go down but we'll
we'll see how this uh ultimately progresses
yeah who do you feel the big bad's gonna
be I think it's I think it's Boca ton I
think that's a nicer version I mean Bo Katan
has played antagonistic before you know like
in Clone Wars before becoming someone who you
make an ally with I mean but look at her Cali
told the nearest Vibes this one like putting her
makeup on for what why are you why are you what
are you getting ready for I like what you're
expecting companies Reflection from Mulan by
herself it read a little cheesy to me when yeah
she's just kind of there sitting and there was
some there was something about him there's no
one here my my logical brain started going off
of there's no one here what are you doing that
could be a fake out of yeah you think like oh
this is sort of a really surprisingly mellow
interaction to start things off and she sort
of doesn't seem she she seems to have withdrawn in
a moment of defense or something like that that I
feel I could easily yeah flip back around to some
kind of impassioned you know attempt to reclaim
although her people abandoned her because now
you have me thinking that's a really interesting
would be nice because Lord knows I mean she was
the right hand of Death Watch and then she was
the right hand of the resistance movement against
Maul and then she was in charge of Mandalore then
lost Mandalore to this accent Clan and then
lost all of Mandalore to the Empire so like
maybe she's learned something and maybe she's
playing no I mean it would be and I think that
would be a really nice Evolution uh because I feel
like right now she's just a little bit too angsty
to be a good villain um where it's just like too
much hate the other thing that I don't understand
is she could just be like hey din could we could
we do a duel and you when you yield I won't kill
you which historically is a totally fine way to
pass off the darksaber um Dave filoni John Favreau
what's up with that that gets you on the phone
yeah don't get me on the phone I need to know
I did notice with Katie Sackhoff they they tone
down a lot of their contrast with her appearance
like she in the in the second season it's very
bright like her hair's a tad longer sure but
even the red in her hair is not as bright and her
skin they I feel like they've really brought the
animated version of her to life and the second
one on here she she looks very human yeah you
know and I appreciated that aesthetically at least
there's a lot of great Aesthetics and great great
blends of like puppeteering that's been sped up
things that are like in that monster battle is
clearly moments that are actual sort of parts of
creatures blends with CGI and stuff like that and
two I think the last thing that came to my mind
is you said that thing about the Galaxy healing
and one thing I've really liked about the recent
stuff like I mean through Mandalorian also through
Andor and now this it's like I I have gotten
used to a version of this where like you check
in on certain planets and there's always reliably
kind of the same all the time and here it's like
the idea that they would change a little bit
depending on when you check in and now we're
seeing at least on Navarro what is there to lose
yeah now that they've started to build back I
think that's also kind of a foundational element
that is kind of a an earmark of the best parts
of more recent Star Wars no I I completely agree
with that and I feel like it's it's nice to see
the sequel Trilogy is beginning to make a little
bit more sense like how did the New Republic end
up just falling apart in the first 50 minutes
of that movie you know of the force awakens
um uh and it's really clear it's it's there is
a regardless of if it's a republic or an Empire
or whatever there's just a distrust um and it
really is a it's a nice reminder that these
planets and these people are alive and these
are different societies that grow and change
um I'm I'm really eager to see what other old
locations uh that will come back to I mean I can't
help but imagine we're going to be on tattooing
at some point and the repercussions of the book
of Boba Fett uh how will that affect you know MOS
Eisley and you know everyone's got a shiny Vespa
now everyone everyone is exactly yeah I I am I am
curious to see like what the real pulse of this
season's gonna be what the through line threat
will ultimately be because I like the the journey
it feels very uh like a very Nomad Wanderer like
to trying to reclaim this uh as part of this Creed
uh but however I I did find myself like itching
for some stakes in this episode I I would like
that to be kind of established yeah like it
doesn't really have that ending like if there's
a criticism I do have it doesn't have that ending
note for me like even the ending with Boca I'm
like well that's not too different than what we
already left off with the season two you know and
so what I'm waiting for is that be like season one
had for a first episode like what is this little
Yoda creature and and then even we had the plot
already set up for season two and then they show
Boba Fett at the end of that one so they had like
some solid seats I think they I think they did it
but in a very subtle way I mean last we saw the
armorer there was only one other follower of the
Creed uh in the form of uh the member of Clan
but that's why I was saying about the Civil War
yeah but and I I feel like there is clearly those
numbers there's a young person that for a while
we thought was the Payless they are rebuilding
baby Pedro did they say what planet that was
no they didn't um no they didn't but that's a
great position they do time spans and they don't
often tell you how much time has passed yeah and
that that part of it can can sometimes needs to be
I sometimes I do think needs to be told because
obviously like I didn't know about John Favreau
saying until like moments before filming this
about how there was a time Jump it's a Time gap
for two years where to me it felt like a couple
of weeks when I saw a book of Boba Fett when grow
goo and John reunite and then obviously a lot of
time has passed here because you know Navarro's
um really and you know I do actually feel like
the character of Kara Doon is was missing for me
uh in in Navarro I did feel her missing presence
yeah but I I think it's actually I like obviously
and there we go uh no I feel like as as the one
throwaway line about like yeah I got recruited
by the new Republic and all that and I do like
that they can play on this notion that like oh
maybe having a new Republic Ranger representing
law enforcement an assistant that's trying to be
independent um wouldn't have worked in the first
place I think the other thing to mention here is
that there is the theoretical they still haven't
officially canceled it the Rangers of the Rangers
of the new Republic sure sure um that I think
implied that this was going to happen anyway
um you know but obviously the
situation is right but yeah
bring her back I say it's been enough
time has it I don't I have no State I
don't know man I don't know either I'm
like I don't even remember what happens
she's friends with Ben Shapiro that's
about all I know well he's he's Jewish
it's all right we we have he needs to go babe a
quarter of Harrison Ford so we're it all checks
out yeah yeah yeah because like the pie when I
was saying steaks like the pirate thing was a
great sequence I love that we got like an actual
aerial battle because you don't really get that
with Mandalorian um that's one of the things I
actually appreciate about this show but it's cool
to actually see that they're really bringing that
to life here two out of ten not enough Hondo anaka
I don't know exactly um but uh but um yeah like
okay the Pirates thing kind of seems like it just
was randomly inserted and I'm not exactly fully
there is nothing about what they introduced with
them that it has me super interested to see how
they affect the rest of the season I don't think
they are I think I think that was just it with it
I think that was more of a a tool to show us that
things that would have been a half a season Arc
are just not like a non like the monster being in
the very beginning as opposed to like the monster
uh in uh when we when we fought the crate Dragon
um being like a much big seem to throw a lot of
attention to the Pirates thing that's going to be
a big thing I feel like that they're going
to be back at some point maybe and also I
don't know the the the changing politics of
Life on Navarro coming from being this more
Dusty like you know Cowboy town where like you
kind of have to tolerate a certain amount of
leeway whereas now they can afford to be
like you know what after a certain point
get out of here Pirates we're not working
with you well that's kind of the interesting
um and maybe the overarching theme of the season
is what fills these power vacuums that exist and
I imagine we're gonna see uh our two X-Wing pilots
from the new Republic who always just happens it's
such a small Galaxy so you should bring to that
one guy it's been the one guy the Asian guy well
he his his voiceover was in the trailer or was
it yeah yeah uh and his name is escaping me but
um yeah but uh part of me wonders
if yeah if the Pirates caving me
yeah I mean I'll end with this uh a five minute
monologue I'll end with this it was amazing uh
seeing Mandalorian culture I'm so excited I hope
that most of the season is spent uh unpacking the
trauma of the Mandalorian peoples yeah John I'm
having a blast happy to be back and I can't wait
for him great effects Great Adventure I'm here
yeah uh I give this one I'm like a a a a glowing
7.5 out of 10. I would say 7.5 yeah 1.5 I mean I
feel like this is the kind of episode that would
grow on me grow goo on me and over the course of
how it plays into the later part of the Season
yeah it's still a recommendation it's still good
well this is a show for me where or both modes
are I'm equally happy for because I'm used to
it being where some episodes are just kind of
on their own and it's just a neat adventure and
then other episodes are very consequential and I'm
kind of here for both but they're always fun and
I feel like it's really fun at Star Wars core like
that's what that's what we keep coming I probably
say like a 7.8 if we're playing with the room here
yeah I'm saying a 10 out of 10 gonna praise the
shrine of Dave filoni when I get home I gotta
edit this for you guys so I'll I'm i'mending this
right now we love you thanks for being here Ryan
Barnes you are Ryan Barnes Baines Baines that
stays Good Golly it's Rob Frawley the second
don't get it twisted you cannot avoid The Keeper
of the Void danger Jeffrey Robinson you've never
heard this reference especially not for me in
one of these videos real whoa you almost got me
parka fan US 101 Freeway jaspreet Boulevard
you can start by car Roberto Engel man I love
that Roberto guy Ian Simon weebu
Ryman it's my lover song High Gaga
Glover Jacob Neptune absorbed the book
Dune all hail Kayla the King baby NMB is
not the National Basketball Association
Alan Ling the guy with the thing Kiara
flesh ericon's 39 Cent Store coosey coosi
rhymes with a word that means a woman's genitals
fill in the blank Puss in Boots The Last Wish
that's what it's about Nick X filling fill in
the blank with something naughty Juan Longoria
yeah I've I've stamps stamps for you it's
never turgid when you're with Gail Ferguson
all right let's see we won Cliff Rodriguez
means business Master tiddlywinks
John the goat wrote me a note Lorenzo's Oil
Baxter building differently sane walks around
with a reliable cane hold still for Marco
ton still Lauren American Horse never feels
any remorse never jaded simply faded always hair
braided Rogue Cree you are not shiny slithering
junkie 94. Justin Martin the pop Tartan don't
flame me Rosie baby Rachel Alden air Reich look
who's balling it's Colin all dollin Stalin Ballin
trolling Philip J Smith Jr you give me a bunion
quite a bunure Jen Smith don't
join the Sith Melanie LeBlanc
ah you you bring out the funk in me haha anyway
guys hey thanks for being part of our patreon
page and watching John and I are lay down these
sick bars for all you guys I hope you're around
next month to hear this all over again where we
recycle some Rhymes without realizing that we've
done that a few times sorry what do you know I
just did it again peace out super sexy Rejects